so here we are in this webpage let's
take a look at what it looks like when
we can see our click locations I'm going
to go ahead and open up the console by
pressing command option J and start
clicking around we can see X location
with a pixel value and Y location with a
pixel value of where we were clicking on
the page for this question I want you to
use this code here to pass X&Y click
values into a function called log clicks
you'll need to write some code here that
will collect the X&Y click values log
clicks is defined in helper j/s it's
going to append the x and y values to a
list and console dot log what you saw
before x location with a pixel value and
y location with a pixel value when you
do everything right you should start
seeing your clicks showing up in the
console